traffici sono quelle volte nella vita in
cui mi figlia una voglia strana non è
quello che pensa tante serie sul mio
canale sono nate perché avevo voglia di
fare una roba
un minuto prima di registrare tipo
adesso stanno scorrendo la home di
youtube
amy è comparso un video che devo
guardare non è niente di kringe è solo
una roba che vorrei poi potrei reagire
con voi
allora ragazzi esiste un canale di
youtube che io seguo da mezz'ora è
praticamente ti fa vedere delle case la
particolarità è che sono case talmente
belle che è costoso ovviamente che
nessuno si potrebbe quasi nessuno si
potrebbe permettere per lui e gli sbatte
in faccia ed è tutto ti a guardarle
perché sono troppo incredibile lo ha
detto provo a fare una reaction a una
roba del genere perché sono talmente
incredibili stemi chiani case che devo
vedere devo commentare con voi questa
cosa mi di fatevi commentare sto mica
divide allora c'è qua parliamo di ok
allora vi faccio una premessa parliamo
di pirlo ha capito se le vendono
semplicemente le fanno vedere è questa
qua parla di
77 milioni a new york quindi una casa a
new york dai vediamo insieme commentiamo
questa cosa attività anche l'indirizzo
salve iniziamo subito con l'acronimo spa
che significa sudici poveri ammirate
piano il piano è questo quindi vediamo
lo comunque è bellissimo perché enorme
enorme abbiamo visto solo la piscina
questo è tutto il piano e nave mouse
peccato per floris a new york ma pure
nel resto direi in 10 giorni questo
workshop voi potete pensare che la gente
si fa il bagno nella vasca norma non ci
deve essere la cascata dal soffitto
perché giustamente che la voi ma vuoi
mai ma mica per i rubinetti i rubinetti
sono roba da poveri ma che adesso suoi
hugo ricchezza max tyson rainy day una
fiaba klein affinche scuole
certo ha detto quando sta piovendo te
vuoi fare il bagno io là dentro so se
piove ci entrò mica se mica tutti i
giorni sono se piove square e archivio
id software
mi piace il bar vicino alla spa che
vuole spa ha appena detto che cosa
sarebbe questa sparse senza la sala
massaggio e sarebbe una me una merda
questa spa pensa talmente i miliardari
che gli fruttò anche lo schienale della
sedia la palestra privata ragazza c'era
anche la felici pervicace di qua ci vai
dopo prima di fare il bagno abbiamo
perché ti stressi per bagno ma poi fiori
teichmann x6 panarari gm
questa precisazione che dice che avendo
la palestra privata come quella in casa
ti permette di risparmiare i soldi per
andare alla palestra pubblica è vero c'è
giustamente cucina ragazzi sta tra
l'altro mi fa mi fa ridere perché già si
vede che è una cucina del cristo ma
neanche guardandola cucite c'è un
elemento che mi faccia girare le palle
che l'orologio coi numeri romani e non
li sanno neanche poi fanno circolare un
orologio e non sa i numeri roma io non
voglio non fare con la faccia che guarda
breakfast room che non è la sede da the
king guarda se pirlo focali non potesse
sempre training magari staresti pensato
ma che bella del tavolo per cenare
questo non è un tavolo per cenare questa
tavola a colazione a colazione
voi vi ricordate la colazione di aldo
baglio quella lì ecco vabbè finisco di
mangiarla beverara essendo no anche se
qua una peperonata ci sta lo stesso la
screening room abbiamo cambiato il piano
che ha meno male perché va beh meno male
che almeno c'è anche di caprio siamo
tutti contenti
questa è una merda tv santa ynez c'è
praticamente c'è un televisore nello
specchio c'è una parte che c'è uno
specchio di 86 metri quindi chi cazzo si
deve specchiare hulk l'hai dentro sto
bene però la parte quello c'è un
televisore incorporato dentro lo
specchio cioè interviste poker come ci
arrivi a si liberi come come arrivi a
quelli di tipo che si specchia in quello
specchio ti prende i libri ok dining
room finalmente abbiamo la dining room
se quella a breakfast figura di questo
ragazze per passare il cibo chiamato
anche posto dove chi nasconde quando
arrivano i ladri questo l'ho visto nei
film
c'è una stanza a letto che non è da
guest c'è una stanza letto che ci va chi
ci vive il ragazzo di casa ma gente di
essere in una coppia marito e moglie
state dormendo insieme poi litigate e
c'è la classica lato don dormi nel mio
letto stasera va bene vado a dormire il
suv a dormire non sul divano vado a
dormire nella stanza degli ospiti che
ancora più bella della tua quindi che
critichiamo apposta volendo con
screening quando bocciò catherine site
grazie al capo giovanni grazie al caf
master suite arriviamo al momento della
monetizzazione ragazzi surround sex for
sesto piano
ci sono sei piani giustamente tu la
palestra che casti serve basta hi fi
piani comunque figo c'è il bagno
chiamato bagno master
suo quasi avevo pensato un ceto medio
per segmento pensa che pensavamo di
avere finiti pianino cioè il piano
superiore sarebbe la terrazza
ma sì è vero un tavolo quando carta
capita e come quando sei minecraft e ai
talmente tanti oggetti da craftare che
diceva venne creato uno in più parlavano
anche gli alberi ma dai ma dai
so esattamente dove perché ci sono stati
quest'estate rebellin è bellissimo
quando la gente diceva quarantena stato
in casa bisogna stare in casa state in
caldo importante salsa però mi fa ridere
quelli che in america che fanno limite
avete mai visti quelli su instagram
dicono state a casa che si possono fare
tante cose e dietro hanno un campo da
golf
il bowling il cinema gesù che la
domenica mattina sta l'aifa l'ha messa
lui quindi a posto
fate voi e io me ne vado in savona ciao
ragazzi
hai finito di farlo solo no